I have a
um
how how to describe this segment so I
used to do a little segment at the top
of the show called Rude to the stage uh
documenting my my weight loss uh
progress and I recently uh ticked off a
nice little Milestone
um I am officially below 220 for the
first time since
August of 2012 I believe so that's
that's good feeling good awesome quite
happy about that and so I wanted to do a
little segment
talking a little bit about some of the
things that have helped me out along the
way uh with with that process because
you know I I've uh quite quite publicly
been a a larger man in the public eye
for uh for I mean over a decade at this
point
um and have quite publicly struggled
with weight loss in the past
um
and
a a good chunk of my uh ongoing success
this time around has been in
um you know like so one of the
one of the uh frequent things that I
would see said about me on the internet
previously was you know like why should
why should I listen to anything that
this person has to say about nutrition
if clearly just looking at them they
don't know anything about it like don't
know what they're doing which like
honestly I get it you know it is what it
is
um but a lot of the the the journey to
where I'm at now I think a lot of what
has helped me is not so much like
learning new things about weight loss it
has been
unlearning things that I used to think
were like absolutely necessary and
mandatory
um that in a lot of contexts are
probably good advice but that
when applied without care and context
can I think sometimes do more harm than
good so I I wanted to talk about that a
little bit uh in this segment so
um yeah the title I have for it is
popular weight loss advice that may do
more harm than good
um and just to add a little Nuance to
that uh you know things that that are
probably in a vacuum pretty decent
advice but
um you know can that have a non-trivial
risk of of leading people astray when
applied without context and so to be
clear I'm not talking about like scams
or like fad diets or anything like that
um you're not gonna do a whole segment
on the grapefruit diet here correct yeah
yeah so I'm talking about things that
are uh the the sort of advice you would
hear from generally well-informed and
well-intentioned evidence-based Fitness
professionals that like I said in a
vacuum might be very good advice but
that I think are sometimes presented as
blanket must-haves that might might not
always be the case so I I think
um I think what I'm getting at will
become more clear as I get into this
segment
um and also uh so just to just to kind
of start out with some some context and
background for where a lot of the
dietary advice in the like so-called
evidence-based Fitness Community
originates and I mean really just the
broader Fitness community in general
um a lot of it kind of
uh originates with or gets popular with
bodybuilders and physique athletes first
and foremost uh which which kind of
makes sense
um so for for people who are
bodybuilders physique athletes like a
huge part of the sport is pursuing what
uh what Adam Fisher our buddy Adam uh
does support for both Stronger by
science and macro Factor great dude got
absolutely diced in this past year but
what he terms exotic levels of leanness
um and you know if that is your Pursuit
if a if a big part of your sport is just
getting as peeled as you can possibly
get it makes sense that you're more
likely than the average person to just
like stew on the approaches that might
be best suited to accomplishing that
that Pursuit because you know that's
that's a huge part of your sport uh and
when you're trying to reach an extreme
goal the details simply matter more you
know what I mean yeah um and I also
think it makes a lot of sense for
for just kind of the general fitness
public to look towards bodybuilders
physique athletes bodybuilding coaches
physique coaches four General nutrition
advice
um you know even if like there there are
reasons you might not want to but just
kind of like on a very basic level it
makes sense because you know if if
you're like that is a population of
people who reliably and predictably
Achieve extreme levels of leanness like
that's a huge part of what they do and
it's it's pretty rare for successful
bodybuilders to
sign up for a show and just show up
completely out of shape you know they're
they're able to pick months in advance
hey I'm doing a show on this date and I
need to be incredibly Lean by that date
and then they get there and I think that
that's extremely appealing for a lot of
people because you know the the thought
process is if they can so reliably and
predictably get that lean
and I have you know I I'm only trying to
get down to 15 body fat or like for
um for the women listening like you know
25 body fat something like that like if
if they can get that peeled then their
advice certainly has to be good enough
to help me get to where I'm trying to go
on a reasonable timeline you know yeah
and we see that with other domains as
well uh where like you'll you'll see uh
people who are like trying to get tips
for running their like one person sole
proprietorship type business and they're
like I'm gonna read a book by someone
who runs a Fortune 500 company with like
70 000 employees about how to manage a
company and it's like well yeah like
those strategies certainly can help you
manage an enormous company but you might
not necessarily need that for your sole
proprietorship or for like a tiny
business that has like two contractors
yeah yeah for sure so
um yeah a point that I'm going to
attempt to make in this segment is that
some of that advice
might be unnecessary at best or
counterproductive at worst for people
who aren't pursuing as extreme of goals
and just as one final like little bit of
framing before diving in
um the context of this segment is I'm
talking about people who are trying to
lose a significant amount of weight and
keep it off so I'm not necessarily
talking about advice for people who are
going into a weight loss attempt with
the intention of kind of doing cyclical
bulks and cuts you know you're gonna
lose 20 pounds trying to get super lean
and then you're gonna regain 20 30
pounds in the off season to try to build
more muscle and then get lean again you
know like a uh which I'll note like
that's also like a kind of common piece
of advice a lot of people give
um
which also just directly comes from
bodybuilders which I I don't know if
that's necessary for everyone but people
with those sort of of uh
who are intending to take a cyclical
approach to Weight Management that's not
really what I'm talking about I'm
talking about folks who are trying to
lose you know 10 20 30 pounds and keep
it off in perpetuity yep
um so uh yeah with with that out of the
way let's dive in
um so ultimately uh I I think a
successful weight loss diet kind of for
that purpose lose the weight and keep it
off uh is going to need to have three
characteristics uh one you need to be
able to stick to it uh to help you stay
in an energy deficit for a long enough
period of time to lose the weights you
want to lose number two uh it needs to
support other goals you have Beyond
weight loss per se you know like if
you're working out you need to have
energy for working out trying to
maintain muscle you need to be able to
maintain muscle needs to be able to gel
with your social life to some extent
um all of those things and and number
three and perhaps most importantly
certainly very important uh whatever you
do needs to set you up for Success at
the end of your diet because again
you're trying to lose the weight and
keep it off so it's not just you know
trying to Sprint to lose 20 pounds and
then you just find yourself on kind of
the yo-yo diet roller coaster lose the
weight gain it all back you want to be
able to to build the necessary skills
and lifestyle around what you're doing
that when you lose weight you'll you'll
be able to maintain that and keep it off
so the the first uh idea I would like to
talk about the first piece of popular
advice that I think often uh might might
be okay advice in a vacuum but that
often does more harm than good when just
given as blanket advice to everyone is
uh the pursuit of rigid macro Counting
and I'm not going to get super in depth
on this because I know I know you've
talked about this on the podcast uh
quite a bit before but uh I'll note on
the front end
that a rigid approach to macro counting
uh makes a lot of sense for bodybuilders
in in a lot of contexts so first the the
general rigidity of it
um you know having uh carb fat protein
targets that you try to stick to every
day with minimal or ideally no
deviations from them that makes a lot of
sense when you're on a strict timeline
where you need to get super diced for a
show on a particular date you know yeah
um there there is an end to date for
that diet and you better get there
otherwise there's not much room for
error and and you just kind of make a
fool of yourself on stage
um which you know that's that's not what
you're doing you know so uh the the
rigidity uh like a rigid approach to
macro counting
um can certainly make a lot of sense for
bodybuilders from from that perspective
uh and also just the approach to macro
counting in particular so you know not
just not just trying to keep an eye on
say total calorie and protein intake but
really trying to keep an eye on each
particular macronutrient having carb
targets for the day fat targets for the
day and really not trying to to deviate
from them much at all
um I also think that makes a lot of
sense for specifically bodybuilders
trying to get super lean so protein
obvious that's going to help support uh
muscle maintenance or you know maybe
even gaining a little bit at the start
of the diet need to have plenty of
protein uh fat makes sense like having
having a strict fat Target Fat's
important for absorbing fat soluble
vitamin
maintaining hormone production Etc and
carb intake also very important you need
energy to fuel your training and the
thing is if someone is trying to get if
someone is pursuing exotic levels of
leanness you find yourself with very
little margin for error at the end of a
diet you know like you're not going to
be eating as much of anything as you
would like to but you you might be
dealing with something where if you
don't hit like your fat Target is really
low your carb Target is really low and
if you eat
10 more grams of fat than you had
allotted for yourself well now carb
intake is so low that you're already
shitty training session is just going to
be even shittier you know or what's that
saying is it robbing Peter to pay Paul
exactly yeah when when you're dieting on
a bodybuilding context toward the end
every time you add one macro you're like
I'm paying for this somewhere else yeah
yeah exactly and the in the inverse as
well like if you you know if you eat 30
more grams of carbs than you were
supposed to and that comes out of your
fat budget you might be looking at weeks
at a time where you're you're really
consuming such low fat intake that it's
it's quite unhealthy you know so the the
really really
um strict uh approach to macro County
and really focusing on each Macro makes
a lot of sense in that context
um but I think that that can that can be
counterproductive for a lot of folks who
have other goals
Beyond just getting diced for for a
bodybuilding show first it's just
generally unnecessary
um like our our general perspective is
that for most people just tracking
protein and total calories is fine most
people's hedonic preferences will wind
them up with enough fat intake to
support fat soluble vitamin absorption
hormone production enough carb intake to
support training
um
and you know you're you're not going to
be uh finding yourself in the sort of
situation where everything is just so
low that those trade-offs get uh really
extreme
uh also like the the uh idea of really
rigid macro Counting
we like you've talked about this a lot
before the difference between rigid and
flexible cognitive restraint
a lot of people refer to all macro
counting approaches as flexible dieting
because you have a lot of flexibility
with food choice but if you're
um you know if you're pursuing
three numbers that you have to hit every
day with very very little room for error
um that that just gives you a lot more
opportunities to fail and lose
motivation
um and uh in in-depth discussion of
maintaining motivation over the course
of an entire diet that's probably a
little bit outside the the scope of this
segment
um but just in kind of broad terms
if you're setting goals for yourself
that are challenging but achievable and
you're hitting them consistently that
can help build and sustain motivation As
you move forward
um but you know if you're putting
yourself in a situation where you're
setting goals and targets for yourself
that aren't strictly necessary for the
pursuit of your goal and you're giving
yourself more opportunities to at least
perceive what you're doing to to be
failing you know if if you're saying man
I gotta get within 10 grams of my carb
Target and five grams of my fat Target
every day while maintaining some
semblance of a normal life that's going
to be quite challenging a lot of people
who aren't
you know pursuing a diet with the
single-minded focus of a bodybuilder
like a lot of times you're just not
going to do that and then you feel like
a failure and then you might hit the
kind of [ __ ] it point and say well I
already went 10 grams over on my fat
today is already a failure so I'm just
gonna eat everything inside because I I
already failed today like that's that's
the situation you can find yourself with
with really rigid cognitive restraint
and it's just not necessary yeah I think
the term you used there was the [ __ ] it
Point yeah yeah in the research I've
seen the what the hell effect and I'm
I'm wondering why they went with with
that one instead of your preferred
version I mean it it the similar
connotations I would say no it's exactly
the same thing but one is more printable
in textbooks yes
um
and then yeah uh finally like it uh
like so with with kind of the framing
device three things for an important
diet you can stick to it supports your
goals Beyond weight loss per se and sets
you up for Success at the end of your
diet I don't know that uh losing weight
with really really rigid macro counting
necessarily does a great job of setting
people up for Success at the end of
their diet because
it does take a really rigid cognitive
restraint to do it and most people don't
want to do that forever you know like if
if you're able to pull it off for 16
weeks six months whatever
um you might very successfully lose the
weight that you're trying to lose but
most people don't want to come within
five grams of a protein carbon fat
Target every single day for the rest of
their life you know so if that does
sound like something that you would
enthusiastically do for the next 50
years then go for it but if you look at
that and say damn I really don't want to
do that every day for the next 50 years
then this might be an approach to weight
loss that that ultimately isn't setting
you up for long-term success because
it's not
uh like the the skills you're developing
to pursue that type of diet aren't the
skills you would need to then be able to
kind of transition to a more normal way
of eating and and ultimately keep the
weight off yeah if I could add a couple
things here yeah yeah go for it number
one you mentioned that a really in-depth
discussion of like uh meeting goals and
supporting or facilitating uh motivation
sustained motivation is a little bit
outside the scope of this particular
segment there's two articles I would
direct readers to uh one is
strongerbyscience.com
slash goal setting and the other is
macro factorapp.com cheat meals uh both
of those go into more detail about uh
sustaining motivation uh motivational
collapse in the context of overeating
and rigid dietary targets and things
like that so I would recommend that for
further detail if anyone's interested
another thing
I think a lot of people might be
confused when they hear this and say
okay well I've looked at the literature
and it says that for long-term weight
loss success uh you know some form of
dietary tracking and just general
monitoring practices seem to be
correlated with success in the long run
and so so people might be hearing this
and saying well what gives if if
monitoring is is facilitating long-term
success why would very precise
monitoring be perhaps not the best
approach and ultimately I think if I
could draw on an anecdote uh I was
helping out with a study where that was
a collaboration with a weight loss
clinic and we would have you know
basically participants would come back
when they hit a certain marker when they
kind of Hit the next milestone in their
weight loss and it was starting to
become really clear the people that were
like cruising through it and the people
that were really struggling and you you
know as a researcher you're in the room
with them right you you have the
opportunity to to chat make some small
talk and kind of pick their brain a
little bit and one of the things that
jumped out to me was the really
successful people who were cruising
through it and maintaining it long term
they were doing a lot of the basic
monitoring practices that we talk about
they were keeping an eye on body weight
and they were tracking consistently but
not rigidly and I think that is the big
distinction that you're getting at here
is you want to track consistently but
you don't want to be super rigid about
hitting three exact numbers precisely
for the rest of your life and
you when I talk with these folks what
they seem to do broadly speaking
is fall into a comfortable pattern where
they're consistently checking in on body
weight uh not hyper fixated on it but
just keep an eye on it you know
um and they are tracking their calories
uh maybe tracking protein as well this
population wasn't doing a lot of lifting
so the protein was kind of secondary
yeah
um but you know what would happen is if
they started to see weight creeping up a
little bit then they would say oh that
that's interesting maybe I need to
tighten up my tracking a little you know
and and get it from kind of cruise
control into like hey it looks like
things are starting to drift a little
bit I'm aware of that early because I've
been monitoring body weight and now I
can take my tracking Precision from uh
seven out of 10 to an 8 out of 10 or a 9
out of 10. and for most applications you
really don't have to crank into that
absolute highest gear where you're
precisely and rigidly tracking
carbohydrate and fat and protein teen
unless you're trying to get to to that
term you've been using of exotically
lean yeah yeah and also I mean like
unless there's
uh unless there's a date at which you
have to achieve a certain body weight or
a certain physique or anything like that
um even just like adherence to the
targets is more of a
uh more of like a fuzzy concept instead
of just like you have to hit the numbers
dead on the head every day so like you
know as as an example if if someone's
trying to lose about a pound a week give
or take
um you know that's that's going to come
with an energy deficit of around 500
calories per day on average or so
and so ultimately if you say need to
lose exactly 20 pounds in 20 weeks to
get to you know whatever physique you're
trying to achieve for a bodybuilding
show then like yeah you need to achieve
that deficit every single day or that
cumulative deficit every single week to
get where you're trying to go
at the exact date you need to get there
if it you know if it's more about
long-term weight loss and hey like what
you know I'm gonna get there eventually
and then I'm gonna try to stay here and
maintain it for the next 20 years or
whatever
um that's that's just unnecessary you
know if there's a day or two a week
where you just say you know what there's
a lot of other things going on I have a
social event coming up I just don't feel
like being in a deficit today you can
just eat at your maintenance intake like
one or two days per week for the week
you're still in a cumulative energy
deficit it's still going to be moving
you towards your goal maybe not at your
intended rate but it's still ultimately
progress you know or
um like I this is also something I see a
lot just when when people discuss this
uh on the internet where you know maybe
their daily calorie targets like even if
they're not tracking macro super super
rigidly their daily calorie Target is
like 1700 calories or something then
they're trying to lose a pound a week
and they're like ah man like I I hit
1800 calories today I hit 1900 calories
today I feel like a failure but it's
like dude like that's still a a 3 400
calorie deficit like it's that is that
is still a a directionally appropriate
thing you did and I think that if if
folks were able to take a step back and
you know adopt a mindset of flexible
restraint instead of rigid restraint
that they would see that that is still a
win like this was still a very good day
um you know perhaps not the absolute
optimal conceivable day given what I'm
trying to do and the rate I'm trying to
do it at but it's still good and and I
think with the with the really really
rigid restraint
um you you find yourself in a situation
where you end up reframing small wins
into unqualified losses and that is that
is not a recipe for Success no I mean
that's a great example and it reminds me
one time I was working with a client and
and there was just stuff going on in
life where really meticulous tracking
and pushing the deficit hard just wasn't
really in the cards for a stretch of
time and I could tell they're starting
to get a little bit disappointed with
some of the you know like ah I haven't
been losing weight lately but weight
loss was the goal and it was starting to
kind of get internally framed mentally
as failure and my biggest thing was like
well wait a minute let's take a step
back
we're like 17 kilograms below where we
started yeah maintaining your weight 17
kilograms below where we started is an
unqualified success yeah no so like even
if you do run into those areas of
friction I know we're talking about a
slightly different thing here in terms
of time scales but like yeah I mean if
you were shooting for a 600 calorie
deficit and you hit a 250 calorie
deficit you're still in a deficit you
know if if you were hoping to lose
you know three pounds this week well
that's not a good example but you get
the idea yeah you you set the goal of
what the optimal Target is but like if
you're still directionally moving in the
right place or way further along than
where you started it is important to
kind of take a step back and look at the
broader the broader picture and say it's
really hard to call this a failure yeah
yeah absolutely so
um like I said I'm I'm talking about
this because the excuse I'm using is
that I I recently hit that weight loss
Milestone and so like for for my
experience with this diet and plenty of
diets that had failed in the past
um I I did previously do what uh I
thought I was supposed to do you know I
I
um I I know a reasonable amount about
nutrition I could calculate like what my
protein Target should be
um you know how many carbs I needed to
support the training I was doing the
rest come in from fat it was plenty of
fat to support vitamin absorption
hormone production I was like okay cool
like I've got my numbers I did all of
this the right way
um and now if I'm serious about my
results I just need to stick to them and
you know I I would do a pretty decent
job of sticking to them for a while and
then as soon as motivation started
flagging a little bit and I started
missing the numbers I would I would just
start to feel like a failure and just
kind of like hit that [ __ ] point
um whereas like for for this attempt
like I still have those same Ebbs and
flows of of motivation but there's been
no there's been no motivational collapse
um you know sometimes I'm losing weight
exactly at the rate I'm intending to
sometimes I'm still heading in the right
direction but at half of my intender
rate sometimes there's just a lot of
[ __ ] going on and I don't want to be
dieting I don't want to be in an energy
deficit uh and I mean that's coming up
holidays are coming up birthday
Thanksgiving Christmas New Year's dude
I'm not going to be trying to lose a
pound a week through all of that so uh
just take a break be in maintenance for
a while and and it's okay uh and so it's
set me up in a position where
um you know I can do a better job of
savoring my successes and it's more it's
more a matter of just kind of of
qualitatively assessing was this a big
win was this a small win or
um you know if I do go way over my
targets one day it's a learning
experience you know like
one day can't
it's impossible for one day to be that
big of a setback unless I allow it to be
a setback in snowball you know so yeah
um yeah just just uh adopting more more
flexible restraint has been huge so that
that first one uh went longer than I
expected it to but I thought that was a
good conversation yeah moving on though
this one will absolutely be short
because it uh more or less restates your
segment from the last episode of the
podcast where you were talking about uh
protein intake targets so the second bit
of advice that I think uh might be
generally good advice in a vacuum but
that sometimes can do more harm than
good when just apply it as a blanket
statement is uh giving people or telling
people that they should select like
quite high protein targets
um
so like I said for for an in-depth
discussion of this uh dear audience
referred to the previous episode
um but yeah with with high protein
targets
um for bodybuilders it can make a lot of
sense like taking a better safe than
sorry approach to protein intake
um because protein intake is very
important for maintaining muscle mass in
an energy deficit and it gets more and
more important the leaner and leaner
someone gets if you're going from you
know 40 body fat to 35 body fat at a you
know reasonable rate of weight loss you
got a resistance training stimulus in
there you don't have to worry about
losing muscle when you're taking off the
last five pounds before a show and going
from eight percent to five percent body
fat
then you probably do need to worry about
it uh quite a bit more and uh you know
again the whole point of the sport is to
be as muscular as possible and as lean
as possible and so if if you can uh if
eating a little bit more protein can
help you maintain an additional half
pound of muscle over the course of a
diet that you know that could be the
difference in placing it at a show so
um it makes more sense to kind of give
people uh better safe than sorry type
protein targets and um yeah I mean for
for most people there there just aren't
those same sets of concerns so uh like
we talked about in the last episode well
I say we like Eric talked about in the
last episode
um the difference between a protein
Target of like 1.2 1.3 grams per
kilogram and say 2.2 grams per kilogram
or above
just doesn't seem to be partic
particularly large or
particularly uh
we don't super consistently observe that
there even is a difference to begin with
in the literature like yeah if you start
getting down to a gram per kilo or below
like that certainly seems like it will
probably have deleterious effects for
the amount of muscle you'll maintain if
you're in a deficit the amount of muscle
you'll gain in a surplus but you know it
it seems like pretty pretty moderate
protein intakes probably get the job
done pretty well for most people most of
the time
um and you know if so previously again I
I used to just use that old heuristic of
a gram per pound just 2.2 grams per kilo
um
and and I really found that that just
didn't work for me
um
so
uh
one of the one of the big considerations
here again with just like a successful
diet is you need to be able to stick
with it and it also needs to accommodate
the rest of your life and it needs to uh
set you up for Success at the end of a
diet and I found that you know when I
was trying to get more than a gram per
pound of protein that basically
necessitated a lot of chicken breast uh
a lot of protein shakes and just like a
lot of foods that I didn't particularly
like and like I I have it easier than a
lot of people do because like I'm an
omnivore like it's going to be harder
for a vegetarian or a vegan
um and like I also just don't have that
many social things I do but if you're
going out for with friends a lot to
restaurants and whatnot
um having a lot of meals with family and
you're trying to get in a gram per pound
of protein with a lot of food options
that are like fattier higher carb then
the choices you'll have to make to hit
that protein Target will probably be
reasonably incompatible with actually
staying in an energy deficit in the
first place and will often require kind
of trade-offs and choices that that lock
you into a diet that you probably won't
want to stick with for the next 50 years
you know it seemed like you wanted to
say something
oh um
I was just kind of smiling because I
I've heard of anecdotes where people
will be like in bodybuilding prep and
they'll be like uh yeah I want to go out
to eat with the family but you know I
have to this is especially people who
sit really really really high protein
targets and they're like yeah so I went
to this restaurant and I said boil me
two chicken breasts and then steam me
some vegetables and if if I even smell
butter near those vegetables I will walk
back into the kitchen you know like they
just create this like special order and
they spend like 30 dollars on the
absolute shittiest dinner they've ever
eaten uh so when you're talking about
how like a lot of times so a lot of
times people do kind of feel like
they're pushed into this situation even
outside of a restaurant scenario where
they're like okay it's the end of the
day or close to the end uh I feel
completely satiated I'm fine I don't
feel like eating but I've only had 1.4
grams per kilogram of protein per day
and therefore in order to hit my protein
Target I'm going to have another meal
just to check that box and in that meal
to make that protein palatable I'm going
to also bring in additional carbohydrate
and fat and and it can get to the
situation where it's like
that that was ultimately if the goal was
fat loss you probably didn't even really
need that extra bump from to get you
above 1.4 that day and you just invited
all these other calories that just
chipped away at your deficit for No No
Good Reason yeah yeah absolutely so you
know you're you ultimately do need to
consume enough protein like not trying
to state that protein intake is
completely unimportant but I do think a
lot of people myself included find that
somewhat lower protein targets
um
are just more compatible with the way
that they want to eat and the way that
they can see themselves eating for the
rest of their lives uh and you know not
most people don't want to live on a diet
of of protein shakes and uh boneless
skinless chicken breasts and broccoli
for in perpetuity yeah
um and I mean also man with with
inflation being what it is a lot of
protein-rich foods are are kind of
expensive so if uh if money's tight
dropping down from 2.2 to 1.4 like there
there might be some some non-trivial
cost savings associated with that as
well well no I mean you always hear like
especially like in in the U.S you hear
college-aged folks who are trying to
build muscle and they're like yeah I'm
trying to bulk but it's so expensive
the vast majority of that expense is
their protein yeah the vast majority
absolutely so uh again like my my issue
with with this bit of advice isn't
necessarily the advice itself in a
vacuum my issue is more with how it's
often like framed and messaged
um so you know for example I think that
saying something like as long as you're
getting in about 1.2 1.3 grams per kilo
you're fine but aiming for 1.6 may not
be a bad idea uh if it's feasible for
you I think that's perfectly fine that
seems to be in keeping with the evidence
um it's not setting 1.6 grams per kilo
as a rigid and flexible Target you have
to shoot for uh but you know if if 1.6
or above isn't keeping with someone's
preferences
um you know it's I'm sure they don't
lose anything by by getting up that high
uh whereas the the way I often see it
framed is just you got to get in 1.6 to
2.2 grams per kilo and bad things will
happen if you don't and I do think that
uh the advice about protein when framed
that way uh has has the potential to to
do more harm than good yeah I think
that's totally accurate and one of the
things that made me smile is like you
had mentioned like a moderate protein
intake
um but but what's kind of convenient is
that this like 1.2 gram per kilogram
general area
like a lot of Americans end up there
unintentionally yeah like if you read
the public health literature sometimes
you'll get like these really panicky
papers that say Americans are overeating
protein and it's a huge problem and it's
like oh yeah we found that they're
eating like 1.2 so a lot of people who
are embarking on a diet might be at the
kind of tail end of this range just
based on their dietary preferences alone
and they might not have to really make
any major changes to get into that 1.2
range yeah yeah for sure uh all right so
moving on the the fourth uh bit of
advice that I think
um makes a ton of sense for bodybuilders
which is which is where a lot of this
stuff originates but may not be the best
just kind of blanket advice for people
to give or receive is the the advice
that I that I see commonly in a lot of
circles that if you're trying to set up
a diet to lose weight one of the things
that you should really try to prioritize
is eating basically as Bland of foods as
you can stomach
um
and so for bodybuilders that kind of
makes sense so with um so the the
thinking behind this this bit of advice
is that human energy intake is regulated
by a lot of different things but
specifically for for feeding Behavior Uh
or eating Behavior you have hedonic and
non-hedonic eating and non-hedonic
eating
um
seems to be in large part just kind of
your your body integrating a lot of
signals related to fuel availability
um satiety long-term energy status Etc
and trying to like tune your appetite to
consume enough calories for survival but
then you know we humans we're not just
uh you know we're not just basically
amoebas uh responding to just cues from
our environment about how much we need
to eat to survive we also have uh food
science and a lot of delicious
ingredients and highly processed foods
that taste very good that you want to
eat in large quantities and um yeah I
mean I'm sure everyone listening to this
has eaten more than they really wanted
to at some point just because the food
was delicious and that is hedonic eating
and
um yeah so if all of the food you eat in
your diet doesn't like really really
trigger that hedonic response that can
that can help cut down on hedonic eating
and and large deviations from your your
dietary goals and targets and I think
that that is the sort of thing that that
can be quite important for for
bodybuilders as they're trying to get
very lean
um
because I think like I mean just from
talking to people who've been there like
your your brain can kind of get in a
state where you haven't eaten
much that's really tasted good in a long
time and when something very yummy is
put in front of you
a lot of people like even if they
generally have like a pretty pretty
normal relationship with food otherwise
just kind of uh
just attack highly palatable very
hedonic food like a feral animal when
they're like super super lean so so like
yeah like that's
um
it makes sense for that population it
gets different yeah so like uh there's a
great paper uh if I remember I'll try to
link it in the show notes but it's about
the uh participants in the Minnesota
starvation experiment and like it really
does get different when you start
getting really really lean like it does
like if you read that paper they don't
say oh when they got lean boy did they
sure get hungry it it's it's psychosis I
mean it is like psychological like
things are different you know like in
that study that they were like okay if
you want to chew gum just to kind of
have you know something in your mouth
and a little bit of flavor go for it and
then they were eating just dozens of
packs of gum a day and they're like okay
you can't do the gum anymore right they
would they would find that people were
just kind of so fixated on food and just
kind of like obsessing over uh thinking
about uh or you know like I've talked to
you know I've heard anecdotes of
bodybuilders who aggregate
and collect cooking supplies and recipes
that they know they can't use for the
next like four months
um but yeah there there are like really
uh pathological psychological kind of
changes that can happen
in the vast majority of cases they are
transient and acute and then once you
kind of get back into the swing of
things they go away but but yeah there's
for bodybuilders there is an application
of this because you will find that when
you're in that kind of semi-starvation
state and you have a really a level of
food fixation that's very atypical for
you and you kind of open the floodgates
by having okay I guess I'll have a bite
of that you can't really put that back
in yeah you know once it's out of the
bag like stuff has a tendency to go kind
of Haywire yeah yeah absolutely and and
the other very important thing to note
is again with bodybuilders you're
talking about a time limited diet uh
you're you're really going to
uh cinch things down really tight for a
period of months to get in insane
condition for a show and that's it then
you go back to eating other stuff but
again if the goal is to lose weight and
keep it off long term
that's that's not really what you're
doing you're trying to build skills that
you can transfer to the rest of your
life and so I think that um I think that
this advice can make sense if it's not
taken to the extreme so
a lot of people run into trouble with
over consuming like like hyper palatable
foods and a ton of just like really
really highly processed refined Foods so
I I'm certainly not saying like oh yeah
like your goal when you're trying to
lose weight and keep it off is try to
figure out how you can be in an energy
deficit while consuming the maximum
number of Pop-Tarts possible like that
that's certainly not what I'm saying
um but I think that the value of
pursuing blandedness of food for its own
sake
um probably isn't a great thing to
pursue for a couple reasons one
is that for most people that's just
going to harm adherence with your diet
like we we live in a world with a lot of
food options and a lot of really yummy
food options and if you're a bodybuilder
and you're you know you know you need to
get on stage in Speedos in three months
and uh and look a certain way when when
that's like
you you need to look a certain way on a
certain date I think that helps a lot
with adherence like
because you you don't want to make a
fool of yourself in front of your peers
in the sport but I mean for for a lot of
folks if you say like hey I'm just going
to have the most bland food possible in
my house all the time and that's the
only thing that I'm going to eat on my
diet and then you stop in a gas station
and see the snacks you need to go to the
store you drive by a restaurant walk by
a restaurant whatever and there are just
so many other much much more delicious
food options there and you don't have
the same sort of like extreme external
pressure forcing you to adhere to your
diet uh then you're going to find
adherence is just more challenging
because everything else that is very
easily available for you to eat just
tastes better than than what you're
trying to force yourself to eat
um this is also going to conflict a lot
with social situations so if you're
if you get in the mindset that I can
only adhere to my diet and not go off
the rails if I'm only eating bland food
then like if you find yourself in a
social situation where you like quote
unquote have to eat more palatable food
like that that might [ __ ] with your head
a little bit
um make it easier to kind of go off the
rails and then lastly like again a big
theme Here is you're trying to you're
the process of losing weight should be a
learning process for developing the
skills that will transfer to the rest of
your life and I mean I I don't think
most people want to live on chicken
breast and rice for 50 years you know so
um there there is
kind of a process you have to go through
of
whatever food you find like you know not
hyper processed not hyper palatable but
but tastes good like it's good palatable
food that you enjoy eating
um
like you you need to be able to
consume that in moderation and uh
find something you can stick to you know
so uh yeah the the fixation on just like
only eating Bland foods and just the
Bland of stuff uh that you can that you
can stomach I don't think sets uh most
people up for long-term success yeah and
there's one kind of assumption that is
uh usually tied to that recommendation
which is like okay you are doing a
bodybuilding style diet which means that
we assume that the the you know calorie
intake and macro intake is fixed right
and so then it just becomes well should
I try to eat really really tasty stuff
to hit that fixed set of macros or some
kind of more bland stuff and the thought
process is generally like well when
you're eating the really hyper palatable
stuff you're you're still eating the
same amount but it's just going to be a
tragedy when the meal ends you're gonna
be like I don't want to stop it's like
well why put yourself through that just
eat some stuff that's a little bit more
boring you're hitting the same macros
anyway way you know it'll just make your
life a little less painful for for this
short term kind of diet
um but when people try to use this
advice in a scenario where macros are
not fixed you know they're not going to
get on stage in 12 weeks so they're
they're like sometimes you'll see people
who say you know what
I'm afraid that if I eat that cookie I'm
going to eat 300 calories or 400
calories worth of cookies so I'm Gonna
Keep to the Bland chicken breast chicken
breast and broccoli and rice
and what they'll do is they'll eat a
serving of that and it clearly didn't
scratch the itch that they were going
for with that kind of hedonic feeding
urge yeah and they say well maybe if I
just eat more of this Bland stuff it'll
scratch that itch and it usually doesn't
um and so like one of two situations is
actually pretty common when food intake
is not rigidly fixed as it would be for
bodybuilders which is either in order to
avoid the 400 calorie cookie Splurge you
eat 400 calories worth of this other
stuff and in terms of energy balance you
end up in the same place yeah yeah um
the other is instead of get you know to
try to avoid that 400 calorie cookie
Splurge you eat like 300 calories worth
of the boring stuff and then say that
didn't really work I'm gonna have the
damn cookies anyway and then it becomes
additive rather than replacing so
sometimes people will think
I can basically tune out my hedonic urge
to eat by really leaning into eating
stuff that will satisfy satiety signals
and they're completely they're not
completely separate but they are
different they're distinct yeah and a
lot of times people think that well if I
just get full or nearly full I won't
have this hedonic urge to eat anymore
and that rarely seems to be the case so
in scenarios where calories aren't fixed
it's not just that this advice isn't as
useful it can actually sometimes
directly backfire in terms of just the
sheer amount of energy intake oh
absolutely uh and then so the the final
thing I have on this list of of advice
that uh I think is is sometimes good in
a vacuum in this case I think it's
advice that really is just good for
bodybuilders uh and really isn't that
good in a vacuum otherwise but but
certainly isn't helpful for most people
is uh a focus on the outcome of a diet
rather than the process of a diet and
particularly kind of time-based and time
limited outcome goals and
I I think that a lot of a lot of times
this isn't directly stated but it's it's
kind of tacitly implied by the sort of
content people put out and the sort of
advice that people give even if they're
not like explicitly saying to focus on
these things
um so you know in terms of focusing on
on outcomes this is a very visually
driven industry
um like people who talk about physique
stuff people who talk about nutrition uh
like there's this saying like your body
is your business card uh which should it
be I don't know maybe not but I mean it
is that's uh that if you're a
professional in this field uh and you
have a much much better physique than
most of your peers that's probably going
to help your bottom line and so it it
makes sense to put that front and center
um but you know what does that tacitly
communicate to your audience like it
tacitly communicates like looking this
way is is valuable and this is what you
should want like you should try to be
focusing on this outcome also just in
terms of how people sell their services
like before and afters are huge which
again makes sense like uh people like to
see someone who who looks similar to
them before and then you know four
months later they have a physique that
that they would kill for you know so but
again before and afters without further
context that is just a focus on the
outcome of of a diet not necessarily the
process
um
and then like the like it's still pretty
common to see people
um
who are doing like General General
Health and Fitness coaching with a
nutrition component
um do do challenges where it's like hey
I'm putting together a group and we're
all gonna try to lose 20 pounds in six
weeks or whatever which again that that
is a focus on a time-based outcome and I
again I think a lot of this for
bodybuilders makes all the sense in the
world that is literally the sport you
start your diet on a certain day your
show is on a certain day you gotta look
a certain way by that day like the the
outcome the physique itself that is your
sport and doing it in a fixed amount of
time that is what the sport entails but
I don't think that is really helpful
advice to trickle down to virtually
anyone else
um the the time it does make sense is if
someone's a strength athlete and they're
trying to like cut to the next lowest
weight class because then it's sort of
the same deal you know you need to be
below a certain body weight on a certain
date for for weighing in but otherwise
like yeah no that's that's just not uh
that's not helpful so I I do think that
I do think that it might be a little bit
useful on the front end because you know
people want what they want and they want
it now they don't want to
if you if you tell someone like hey you
can have the physique you want in four
months or we're gonna focus on the
process maybe you get there in four
months maybe you get there in two years
just as a sales pitch we're gonna get
there in four months is way way more
appealing but then once you actually get
into it
um it circles back to a lot of the the
things we've been talking about to this
point like if you're trying to lose x
amount of weight in X weeks and you fall
behind and you really have a rigid end
date you know now you have created for
yourself a potential Vector for failure
where one doesn't need to exist like if
it's more of an open-ended thing you're
just trying to lose weight you're and
you're focusing on the process of
building the skills necessary to stay in
an energy deficit do it in a way that's
that's feasible and sustainable for you
building the skills to uh maintain that
weight loss at the end of a diet
um you know maybe you fall a little bit
uh behind schedule so to speak but
you're learning a lot through that
entire process and with a with a process
orientation rather than an out than a
outcome orientation it gives you just
more
more just room and Grace I suppose
um to to build those skills and to
interpret setbacks and falling behind
schedule and all of that stuff less as
um less is a failure less is an
indication that you are likely to fall
short of your goal of achieving a
certain look or a certain amount of
weight loss by a particular date or in a
certain period of time and it's easier
to reframe those as learning
opportunities like if you if you had
some strategies that had been working
well for you to stay in an energy
deficit everything seemed pretty
feasible and then just for for a week
the wheels fall off you're finding it
really really challenging to stick to
your your dietary targets you have a ton
of Cravings Energy's low uh diets just
really going poorly
um
you can either step back and say oh no
like I'm trying to reach this goal in 12
weeks and instead of moving forward for
a week I've moved back for a week so now
I'm functionally trying to reach the
same goal I had before but only in 10
weeks because I just took a step back
and this week was already so hard like I
I I'm already regressing so like now I
have to be even more aggressive to get
where I'm trying to go on a certain date
and it like that that is that's not a
recipe for Success like it's it's no
wonder why people lose their motivation
when they when they have that mindset if
they hit any speed bumps whatsoever and
I mean news flash you're gonna hit speed
bumps
um but if it's more of like a process
oriented thing you're not quite as
focused on the outcome certainly not in
a Time limited space
you can step back and say hey this week
was [ __ ] why did this happen you know
um maybe some of the strategies that
have been working up to this point uh
are becoming less effective maybe it's
just other stuff going on in my life and
I need to give myself some Grace and get
out of the deficit be in maintenance for
a while like I I don't need one more
stressor in my life right now everything
else is crazy uh but I can take the
lessons I've learned to this point and
once things calm down use all of that to
get back on track
um it's it's just not
it's just not a helpful orientation just
the extreme time-based outcome focused
uh approach to weight loss
um but one thing that comes to mind is
that you know some people have asked us
why the default behavior and macro
factor is so for example if you go 400
calories over your Target on Monday why
don't they you know why doesn't that
pull that out a Tuesday or maybe pull it
out of like Tuesday and Wednesday and if
you want you can you can make the app
behave that way you know there's a way
to do it but it's not the default
behavior and it's exactly because of
what you said it's like in most cases
you know when when you had a Target and
you went well above it that means that
there might have been some challenge
leading into that that discrepancy
between Target and observed intake and
the last thing we need to do is say you
know how it was so hard to hit this
target yesterday that you went 400 above
it
guess what that challenge might still be
present but it's going to be even harder
because now in the presence of this slip
up we're going to tighten the screws
even more yeah and it's not just that
we're going to get back on the horse but
we're actually Shifting the targets
downward to make it even harder to get
there
um and like you said if you get really
locked into that short time scale
outcome focused time dependent goal you
start to put yourself in a situation
where it can become immensely
overwhelming and stressful yeah yeah and
I mean it's it's the same thing with how
uh like gold progression Works in macro
Factor as well like you know uh when you
set a goal uh the app tells you
essentially like hey if you stick to
this rate of weight loss or or weight
gain but we're talking about weight loss
in in this segment if you stick to this
precise rate of weight loss this is the
date at at which you'll reach your goal
um and I I think people I think some
users expect us to like enforce that end
date rather than the updates to be
informative like hey to continue losing
weight at the rate you want to this is
what you should aim for and they'll say
like you know hey I was trying to lose
um 20 pounds in 10 weeks and I'm five
weeks in and I've only lost six pounds
and the app isn't dropping my calories
really low to try to to try to get me
there by what I thought my end date
would be
um and it's it's kind of the kind of the
same deal you know if like diets get
harder the longer you do them and if it
has been like if if it was already a
challenge to lose 10 pounds in the first
five weeks like if you already fell
behind that that timeline
odds are pretty low that we could
increase the target rate of weight loss
by 50 percent and still get you to 20
pounds in 10 weeks you know what I mean
yeah
um and so yeah it like we like
ultimately we want we want success to
snowball but we want to be able to put
the brakes on setbacks before they can
snowball into like true robust failures
yeah
um and yeah I think that a really
outcome focused time-based approach to
weight loss inverts that
um where uh you know if you're if you're
rewarded for anything like getting ahead
of schedule
um you know that involves eating even
less than your targets losing more
weight quicker
um
and you know like you're you're
uh functionally rewarded for being extra
restrictive
and then if you fall behind again
because you were like it's just it's
just [ __ ] hard to stay in a
consistent energy deficit if you find
that challenging on the front end of a
diet if you then make the diet even
harder as you go along like you're
you're putting people in aggregate in a
scenario where
um you you can't get that far ahead it's
hard to feel that good about the success
that you're achieving but boy if you
fall behind instead of putting the
brakes on on those deviations and and
small failures like they can they can
really snowball into just full-on
motivational collapse yeah
um so yeah really the the point I'm
trying to make in in Broad Strokes with
this segment
is that I think a lot of the advice that
is given in the fitness industry from
well-informed well-intentioned people
tacitly has
kind of the underlying assumption that
food has little value for its own sake
that you'll always be able to stick to
your diet and that you're aiming to get
as lean as humans are capable of getting
so in essence
the advice kind of the the tacit
underlying assumption is if you
perfectly execute on all of these things
you will get diced
um and really the the optimal body
composition outcomes the only thing that
matters and therefore this is good
advice that you should follow and if
those assumptions are true
then yeah it's good advice that you
should follow but that is not how most
folks are you know uh food does have
value uh beyond the physique it can help
you achieve it tastes good their their
social value to it cultural value to it
um you know the the assumption that
everyone will always perfectly stick to
their diet that is quantifiably a bad
assumption so it's less about saying hey
I'm going to assume everyone listening
to this advice is robots and with that
assumption I will tell them how to
perfectly achieve their physique goals
um
those aren't the people in your audience
you know like they're it it is more
about
helping people develop strategies to do
good enough for long enough to get where
they're trying to go and then be able to
sustain it uh so I think for most people
the the stakes and ultimate goals of a
diet are different than they are in for
for bodybuilders and bodybuilding prep
coaches uh and
quote unquote good enough is good enough
uh and the the real goal is that you're
aiming to build skills that will help
you maintain weight loss and you're
aiming to find a style of eating that
you would be happy to stick with for for
the rest of your life and so I think
that's I think that's the lens as a
consumer of information that you should
view advice through
um you know something that might be
excellent advice if you could do it for
the rest of your life might also be
advice that you just have no interest in
implementing for the rest of your life
and if that's the case
it's probably not advice that you want
to to implement while attempting to lose
weight because ultimately
you're going to have to drop that and do
something else once you lose the weight
and now it's time to maintain that
weight loss so I think it's generally a
better approach to
um to focus on those things and build
those skills along the way instead of
separating kind of diet life from post
diet maintenance life like you're yeah
it's a process of of finding something
that uh once you get out of the diet
you're perfectly happy to eat the exact
same way you were during the diet are
very very similar with the sole
exception of hey now you can eat a
little bit more yeah yeah I think uh I
think this is great advice the one thing
I would add to it which I assume that
you would agree with is you know we've
talked in recent weeks a lot about
inter-individual variation and response
variability and the the underlying
premise of those conversations is that
different people are in fact different
people yeah and they will respond to
things a little bit differently
um and I know that just from
observations like you and I have very
different dieting experiences yeah you
know the uh the way that we approach it
the things that help us succeed are
quite different
um and so I I would say that for the
vast majority of people
um you know what you're saying here is
is going to lead them in a better
Direction than just the the kind of
standard approach which is oh let me
take bodybuilding advice and apply it to
a much different weight loss scenario
but I would encourage people
if some of these things based on your
experience have helped you
that's okay you know you don't have to
work your way toward the norm if you
have past experience or experiment you
know you've experimented with some
things and found oh I kind of respond
differently than most folks so like for
example
um I've tried to do uh really laid-back
approaches to dieting and I struggle
with them because I've done a lot of
um I've done a lot of reflecting on this
because I look at the literature that
says exactly what you're saying exactly
and I'm like
but it doesn't match my reality and I've
done a lot of uh reflecting on that and
I think what I've come to find is that
perhaps because of my dieting history if
I take a a really relaxed approach to
weight loss dieting
it doesn't get into The Sweet Spot of
goal setting where it's challenging
enough to excite me yeah and so it's not
that I get demotivated by Falling short
of the goal it's that I get demotivated
because the goal is not yet exciting
enough to me it's not as it's not
challenging enough to get my foot in the
door and to get rolling with it yeah and
so like some people might find things
like that or some people might find you
know what for me and the way that I eat
uh you know I'm just really sensitive to
hyper palatable Foods even if I'm not
absolutely shredded and so for me it's
best to kind of keep things at no more
than like a seven out of 10 on that like
hyper palatability scale some people
might find like high protein maybe for
you hedonic eating is not a challenge
during your your dieting process but
satiety is something you really struggle
with and you find that maybe even going
above 2.2 grams per kilogram helps you I
I think it's or it could just meet your
food preferences better exactly yeah
some people just really really love a
ton of very lean protein-rich Foods
I I don't know how makes no sense to me
but those people exist and I'm certainly
not going to tell them they're they're
wrong for that preference yeah yeah so I
just wanted to in the interest of being
fully comprehensive I wanted to leave
that door cracked for people so that
they they feel uh encouraged to
experience their own experiences and
actually utilize that information you
know I I think whether it's training or
nutrition or some of the psychological
elements of interventions it is
important to lean on your own
experiences and take them seriously I I
agree and just to just to add two things
one like to to
just reiterate something I said up top
but to make it very clear a lot of this
stuff is good advice in a vac in a
vacuum yeah but becomes unhelpful advice
if it leads to issues with
implementation but if you've tried like
if you've taken some of this advice on
board implemented it and it didn't lead
to issues with with implementation and
sticking with it long term then it is
great advice in a vacuum and it's great
advice for you you know like you said it
matches your experience works well for
you the other thing I'll say is that
um with a with a lot of your your
experiences like like that you noted
some of the things you found for
yourself that uh seem to comport better
with some of this advice and seem to
conflict a little bit with the
literature I wonder if it's a bit of a
chicken and egg scenario where the the
people
for whom bodybuilding advice like
bodybuilding type nutrition advice
works well and and matches well with
their psychology doesn't lead to to
issues with implementation and adherence
I wonder if those people are just the
folks who are disproportionately likely
to become bodybuilders in the first
place I I was thinking about that
um when I was like well I don't know
some of this stuff has been really like
when I because I have intentionally said
no I'm going to be more compatible with
the literature and take a more chill
approach to my next diet and I just
can't get into it so yeah I do think
that uh
I do think that to some to some extent
bodybuilding is an innate stable trait
of a human being yeah rather than it is
a uh a hobby or Pursuit like I I do
think that there are some of those
traits that are fairly stable and
persistent in me that nudge me towards
certain approaches to dieting yeah I
think it's I mean most
works as a whole select for for
different types of people
um you know like it to to be a power
lifter
um there's a certain
there's a certain level of psychosis you
need to have to get very far in the
sport because uh I mean
I'm sure I'm going to make some people
upset by saying this but there are
inherent risks and dangers associated
with the sport that aren't inherent to
all forms of General resistance training
um
like
catastrophic things can happen when you
have 700 pounds on your back uh they're
unlikely to happen they generally don't
happen but when you walk that weight out
like you feel it you know that if if
something goes astray my life could
irrevocably change in this moment for
the worse well yeah and like you know it
like an equipped bench presser yeah uh
many of them are very familiar with what
it feels like when your radius and ulna
are bending start flexing yeah yeah
that's an unusual thing yeah and so it
that the sport selects for a type of
person who isn't just comfortable with
those things but who likes those things
which is which is atypical and so I
think that I think that bodybuilding is
similar like I think it selects for
people with like particular personality
types and particular uh relationships
with with food their own bodies like
satiety cues and signals all of that
stuff that probably in aggregate differs
from population Norms to a to a pretty
large extent yeah which further just on
a fundamental level calls into question
the utility of
you know just just normal folks trying
to lose 10 20 30 pounds and keep it off
taking
advice that bodybuilders have uh
developed and found to be very effective
for themselves and other bodybuilders
yeah yeah it definitely reinforces that
point and I I think you know your
segment does a good job of saying like
here is
the bodybuilding toolkit yeah and here
is the not bodybuilding toolkit and what
I would and I'm sure you would encourage
people to do is give yourself access to
all the tools right so like a lot of the
people who are really into this kind of
bodybuilding oriented advice say no that
other stuff doesn't work that that's not
serious enough to work and then people
who Embrace these other sets of
approaches might say oh that
bodybuilding stuff way too rigid it'll
never work for anybody the ideal
scenario is grow your tool kit you know
figure out what's going to work for you
but don't feel like just because you're
losing weight or you want to lose weight
that all of a sudden you're locked into
the body to the lifestyle of a
bodybuilder in 1985 with a fanny pack
and the the white and black pants they
need to bring those pants back they need
to bring actually fanny packs are coming
back yeah but I hear people are wearing
them like around their shoulder yeah
that's not the same
it's not a fanny pack anymore it's not
yeah